hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to air control reportedly
one of the most broken games ever made
and a lot of the internet is debating
whether that was done intentionally to
be a terrible game or if that was just
some attempt to make a great game but I
don't really care because broken games
can make me laugh and if this game could
make me laugh then it was definitely
worth the $6 I paid for it on Steam but
I must admit the fact that there's an
airplane underwater at the entry
screening and aircraft simulator is
probably not a good sign for this game
a long time ago airline leaders met in a
circle with their weapons drawn and then
of course war started I was in casual
mode air control do you know what does
it mean oh oh oh oh this is gonna be a
fantastic game I can already tell whoa
okay then is that earthbound music what
in the world are all these buttons
locked cursor lock okay do I need to
enter a secret combination some sort of
satanic ritual then I need to do how you
doing pilot by the way Oh
oh this is really good why do I have a
health and clips and ammo counter is
something about to happen on this
airline sir so oh hi well hello all you
soulless devil passengers I'm gonna be
your flight attendant my name is Mark
EMU what can I do for you today
wow that Mouse is gonna be very annoying
oh hello just wanted to get a better
look at you sir do i do I do anything
please dear bring this cup of coffee to
the old man in the first who who am I
talking to
what cup of coffee god this mouse is
gonna be super annoying Oh boom oh no oh
you both Hey oh thank you dear not at
all please makeup salon do you see these
pillows no do you are their imaginary
pillows floating in front of your
eyeballs okay pilot I think there's a
deranged man in first class also I I'm
pretty sure I'm deranged ooh oh that oh
is that a pillow
okay thank you dear not at all
oh hello oh there are more pillows I'll
just click those till they go away thank
you dear
compartment is so clear now why was it
unclear in the first place
hello magic hey dear could please check
out how is it in a pilot cabin Oh Oh was
this game made by 4chan collectively
like them trying to count to a hundred
ok you are ready
what am I ready for whoa pilot I'm not
that kind of guy okay now it is a time
to feed passengers I was reading that oh
man oh man
cool Cola and meat please meal please no
bread Cola and meal please no bread what
in the world : meal please no bread what
does that mean oh I don't know what you
mean
Oh God everyone wants Cola and meal
please
what is colloid meal plays I expect the
comment section just be flooded with :
meal please no bread : meal please no
bread go and mail please no bread I'll
be right on that please bring this food
to the three passengers in the first bit
okay the ones that wanted : meal please
no bread no bread oh nice okay give me
oh give Cola give meal very good I am
proud of you thanks dad take it a small
gift from me you got a thousand success
points excuse me Oh mod menu zombies Oh
zombies art Wars zombies please what is
your free time go and speak with them
you need to find blacksmith I need to
find a blacksmith Oh Oh I do
hi oh I need to find the blacksmith
hello zombies starting to now think that
I should have gone with the dwarves
oh hello man what is your name I do not
want okay tell me something about you
please I am blue Abadie Appa die would
you like to help me no anyway will you
help me her she will die oh my people
are hungry can you please give me some
food negative 20 meals and negative 20
colas oh hey catch thank you my dear
what the did I do it
uh I am Elton zombo's are you our new
stewardess no just a striptease er great
we needed you so much
why would you need me why would you need
me I like you plain Oh God I you are in
a zombie Confederate on plane much
better than the other
do you like Dwarves I like Tours we hate
dwarves and people we are the best
are you we're gonna start a war are you
with us no but yes okay oh god what am I
done
I didn't see you okay I am zombie step
I'm 5,000 years old I will have a
birthday hundred years later I hope you
will come dear you liked words no but
yes okay goodbye I didn't see you who
are you
I'm blacksmith I found you I found you
after all these years of searching okay
dear yeah Wow well we will we whoo-ahh
what just happened why am i back here no
why am i back here I just found the
blacksmith you can't take em away from
me
oh hello well you're new what is
happening well hello there's a terrorist
on our plane you need to find him hint
here's a zombie
okey hello hello
oh hello hi do yes son of a [ __ ]
hey money fame girls what do you want
shut up [ __ ]
I'm a pink horse coke
alright okay I'll go with you Frick
Frick fastly coke oh dear can you please
clean up the compartment oh oh where why
how and why and why and where all right
whatever
come Armand is now clear thank you what
no it was not clear it wasn't clear who
are you what how are you sir
I don't know please tell me why do you
need to know so badly okay what are they
planing what are they playing nice pan
zoom thing I do not know air control do
you know what does it mean oops it looks
like terrorists are trying to steal the
plane you need to stop them then go to
pilot oh sorry mm thank you wait where'd
my my mouse is a beard Bowie whoa nice
load
what the hell all right then hello pilot
wait what I did try SuperSpeed whoa wait
wait whoa whoa whoa hey don't okay I am
dead you're on the world's longest plane
every girl's dream Oh God uh okay I got
this disabled that I have my mouse back
well whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo okay all
right okay then
what do you know that it does mean what
I don't know that it does mean check our
plane on terrorists hi
nice helmet was that a terrorist
ba-ba-boom and you exploded just as I
imagined you to do that alright Tom do
the second floor apparently hello any
terrorists up here no okay
excuse me why am I here after after what
I don't even know oh I'm on the field
now alright bring it on you have
survived the catastrophe go to the
airplane how how did this happen who did
this who did this okay I'm dead
apparently okay did not notice that can
I climb that no okay I'm dead then oh oh
oh oh alright then
oh oh oh alright then thank you I needed
this what is that go to the airplane
which one you're not being very specific
game I think I'm about to lose my sanity
here it really might be crazy to say
this I'm starting to enjoy myself I'm
starting to have fun whoa find the city
land in the city space to launch the
engines oh I gotta hold it where were
you we will wait whoa whoa hey whoa hey
whoa okay pull back on the throttle the
liftoff wait aah
Oh incoming steady Oh God
I'm the terrorist oh I won
whoa a one-eyed added light whoa okay
why that's moody okay
gammy [ __ ] no oh I crashed Oh screw you
don't play don't press on game next
oh we're apparently the airplane is
falling down falling down falling down
use your survival instance head towards
the front of the plane that's the place
of lease result I jumped well then oh
why I did not get in a parish okay all
right you survived a POW how did I
survive the catastrophe Wow your mission
is to put the track on the green life
bus boy come on get with it truck get
the thing to the green light I don't
know what that means
okay let's go and now I'm on shrooms
good lord a low oh I'm going to vomit
I'm legitimately gonna vomit I'm
probably gonna cut this part out because
I all why does it have to be sickly
green and now we crashed again why might
I ask
oh I'm slow in the desert apparently oh
hello that's mildly creepy all of a
sudden hello
sorry helicopters only in fallout 4
okay okay let's go wait wait it's
another one of these scenarios but this
time third portion okay here we go
picking up speed seem to be stuck going
left alright don't mind that wow this
actually is gone oh never mind it's not
nice Oh
okay what am i doing now and in fact why
am i doing I could swear I just got a
helicopter it's my brain melting on my
ears let's just finish this cuz why not
ba ba ba BOM and everyone is slowly
sinking into view
oh it's a return to the beginning okay
never mind the airplane is seeing you
find a way to save the passengers
how about screw them save me I'm
obviously on some weird drug trip sorry
everybody this is our last hurrah so
we're just gonna sing ourselves in the
death we're gonna be marching through
the gates of Hell together arm-in-arm
singing kumbaya my lord kumbaya do you
wanna build a snowman do you wanna go
out and but I live in our little is he
really do you black little gravel you
out and literally I am or dead Oh
doctors I somewhat questioned your
medical expertise in this department but
don't mind me just gonna clean cleaning
cleaning who needed these anyway who
even needed these what kind of sick
medical conference are you all going
okay I'm done apparently well that did a
number on okay okay let's go would you
survive the hill god who's next who else
wants a piece of me huh huh well alright
then think I might have reached the end
of the game maybe maybe when the
developer mind
well now okay
okay royal star Knights are transporting
the gold in his Blayne go and close the
shelves apparently whoo whoa Nelly okay
let's go
Chris space to jump okay I was about to
say if you made me played flappy plane
on this stupid game I would have been
out of here everything else was fine up
until that point bring this cup of
coffee
well that's kind of the first thing I
did in this game hello man thank you not
at all
alrighty then pick up this little on
it's just looping over and over it he's
gonna live this is gonna loop over and
over isn't it oh yeah ready
oh no no no y flappy plane hey I'm doing
pretty good
why isn't keeping scar I want to do very
good on this I wanna have good score oh
wow good score what I play here's ooh I
hear lave lobby boy I have a lobby plane
next please ok oops oops looks like
Terrace they're stealing I am playing
the same name game of a thing before
doctors don't laugh yeah ok I jumped out
again good for me
not floppy plane again oh oh oh oh it's
done oh I did it
don't say next oh I did it
oh I survived it realistic mode updated
I don't even know what that is it was
part one of the game unless I went to
the part two I don't know do I dare I
dare all right there Oh
oh don't make that end I wanna the game
crashed well God for the game that's
fantastic for the game
so either way that's the end I'm done
this game oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no I was done I was done
with this game Oh No again every season
funny I always earth seeds and big kudos
to you maybe fans and other world trying
to versus alright you know I'm done I
don't even know I'm trying I'm done I'm
done I'm out here I'm done I'm done to
the main menu I'm done that's it thank
you all so much for joining me on this
incredible adventure that was air
control I can see what the internet was
talking about now so it please
understand that my suffering through
this game is a warning to you guys so
that you don't have to play it but if
you want you it's on Steam it's still
there for some reason so there's a
secret that I'm not seeing or some other
hidden gem in this game other than the
great gameplay that I saw let me know so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos and I've done probably good games
and as always I will see
Oh in the next video I smell bad I also
have bathroom really gosh not virtual
reality reality Oh what the heck that's
of different magic